but I believed very strongly that we  could build a different kind of company  I never believed never I think it would  have been arrogant to believe that we  could have a thousand 2,000 or 7,500  stores in the US and around the world  but something really magical started  happening and it started happening as a  result of not advertising or  conventional consumer classical  marketing the fact is that Starbucks  spends very little on traditional  advertising it started happening because  we demonstrated to ourselves and now the  world that to build an enduring  sustainable long-term business and  consumer brand it's not about fancy  marketing it's about establishing a very  powerful and unusual emotional  relationship with the customer